die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Jana
pareigis schönen guten Abend und
willkommen viel Fußball gleich von
Norbert Lehmann
und darauf schauen wir noch in dieser
Sendung
starkes Signal an die Ukraine die Nato
und ihre Partnerländer versprechen Kiew
langfristig Waffen und Munition
das heizungsgesetz im Bundestag die
Regierung wirbt für ihren härterungen im
Kurs die Opposition spricht von einer
Zumutung
und wieder tote Fische in polnischen
Kanälen für warschau ist es ein
Warnsignal und auch in Brandenburg macht
man sich Sorgen
der ukrainekrieg wird sich noch länger
hinziehen so die Einschätzung der
sogenannten Ukraine Kontaktgruppe das
sind rund 50 Staaten die das Land
unterstützen heute haben sie sich am
NATO sitzen Brüssel getroffen und der
Ukraine auch langfristig weiter
Militärhilfe zugesichert ein Bericht von
ultra
der Nato-Generalsekretär Stoltenberg hat
eine einfache Botschaft mitgebracht der
Krieg dauert lange deshalb müssen mehr
Waffen produziert werden
stellen dass die gelieferten Waffen auch
weiter funktioniert wir müssen dauerhaft
genug Munition und Ersatzteile
produzieren damit wir kämpfen können
das große Thema auf dem Treffen die
gegen Offensive der Ukraine in der NATO
sieht man Erfolge und Geländegewinne
aber keine erwartet einen schnellen Sieg
der Kampf ist ein Marathon kein Sprit
wir werden der Ukraine alles zur
Verfügung stellen damit sie jetzt
erfolgreich ist aber auch in Zukunft
keine Angst mehr haben muss vor einer
russischen Aggression
dazu gehört für den ukrainischen
Verteidigungsminister resnikow die
NATO-Mitgliedschaft Fragen allerdings
wurden dazu nicht zugelassen
nicht so lange Krieg sein mache die
Diskussion keinen Sinn deswegen steht im
Augenblick wenn ich das noch mal sagen
da vor allen Dingen die anhaltende
substanzielle Unterstützung der Ukraine
im Vordergrund und nicht die Spekulation
darüber was nach dem Krieg sein wird
für die substanzielle Unterstützung der
Ukraine hat die NATO die
Rüstungsindustrie eingeladen sie kann
mit milliardenschweren Aufträgen rechnen
worüber wir uns immer unterhalten und
ich glaube das funktioniert jetzt auch
wir dürfen nicht reden über ein oder
zwei Jahre wir müssen über einen
Zeitraum von sieben acht neun zehn
Jahren reden um dann auch vernünftig
produzieren zu können um sicher zu sein
um genügend Vorräte zu haben
die ukrainische Fahne weht über
befreiten Gebieten die Armee hat sie
gehisst um Erfolge zu vermelden aber
einen schnellen Sieg erwartet niemand
Florian neuhahn vor dem
NATO-Hauptquartier in Brüssel warum saß
jetzt erstmals die Rüstungsindustrie mit
dem Tisch
naja wenn man die Ukraine langfristig
mit Munition mit Waffen ausrüsten will
und wenn man auch noch die eigenen Lage
der eigenen Armeen wieder auffüllen will
um sich eben selber verteidigen zu
können dann braucht man dafür zwingend
die Rüstungskonzerne und diese Konzerne
sagen sie brauchen eben langfristige
zusagen und Perspektiven Bestellungen
von Seiten der Staaten und so war das
heute aus Sicht beider Seiten mal
sinnvoll sich da eben hochrangig hier im
NATO Hauptquartier erstmals
auszutauschen vor allem aber zeigt
dieses Treffen auch ja einen gewandelten
Blick auf die Rüstungskonzerne die vor
ein paar Jahren sicher noch so eher in
der Schmuddelecke der deutschen
Wirtschaft waren heute eben gern
gesehene Gäste sind hier im NATO
Hauptquartier kleiner Nebeneffekt rein
Metall etwa hat im letzten Jahr bereits
einen Rekordgewinn gemacht und der
Vorstandschef sagt die mir gerade im
Interview man wird diesen Gewinn in
diesem Jahr noch mal deutlich
übertreffen
danke Florian neuhahn
blicken wir direkt in die Ukraine dort
versuchen ja derzeit die ukrainischen
Streitkräfte verstärkt Gelände von den
Russen zurückzuerobern unter hohen
Verlusten über die besonderen
Schwierigkeiten der ukrainischen
Gegenoffensive Berichte Thomas Gonsior
ein Feld ein Schlachtfeld bei bachmut
mühsam kämpfen sich pro ukrainische
Soldaten durch zerfurchte Erde durch
Gänge und Gräben angelegt hat sie das
russische Militär aus der Luft sieht man
labyrinthische russische Stellungen
Unterstände fallen und anderswo
panzerhindernisse wie die sogenannten
Drachenzähne all das errichtet während
Kiew Monate lang auf Waffen wartete
sagen Experten
ja durch die Verzögerung in der
Waffenlieferungen hat Russland Zeit
gewonnen um sich quasi einzugraben und
einzugraben heißt was sie
Verteidigungsstellungen anzulegen die
jetzt den ukrainen Probleme bereiten
konkret gibt es überall an der Front
russische Befestigungsanlagen auch
erdwelle und Minenfelder etwas Gelände
gewann die Ukraine zurück sagt Kiew bei
bachmut 500 Meter bei saporicia immerhin
drei bis sieben Kilometer was braucht's
damit schneller geht zum Beispiel im
Innenraum Panzer also minenroller oder
dreschpflegepanzer und der
brückenlegepanzer und das macht es dann
möglich weil sie die Artikel Hindernisse
entsprechend überwinden zu können das
reicht aber nicht denn beim Vorrücken
verlor Kiew viele Soldaten tragisch und
ein strategisches Problem denn Militärs
sagen um hier durchzubrechen braucht die
Ukraine etwa viermal mehr Soldaten als
der Gegner und viel mehr Unterstützung
aus der
lufthan Flugzeuge um hier auch diese
Dimension entsprechend abdecken zu
können Militär Nachschub
eine Bedingung für größere ukraineische
Erfolgsmeldungen die anderen Zeit und
Geduld
und um die ukrainische Gegend Offensive
geht es auch bei heute live los geht's
um 19:30 Uhr in der ZDF heute App und
auf unseren Social Media Kanälen
das heizungsgesetz hat es in den
Bundestag geschafft heute gab es die
erste Lesung und die wurde zu einem
Schlagabtausch noch sind zahlreiche
Einzelheiten des Gesetzes offen die
Ampelkoalition will das Gesetz bis zur
Sommerpause verabschieden die beginnt am
7 juli viel Zeit ist also nicht mehr
über die Debatte im Parlament berichtet
Andreas Huppert
ein bisschen gehetzt wirkt er schon der
Bundeswirtschaftsminister irgendwie
symbolisch denn auch der Gesetzentwurf
für das anstehende Gebäude Energiegesetz
kommt auf den letzten Drücker und wie
der dann ganz genau ausformuliert ist
steht auch noch nicht fest weshalb die
Opposition gleich zu Beginn erstmal
fordert das ganze abzusetzen die
Vorbereitung zu kurz den Wurfs wir
sollen also heute über
ein die Regierung will hier einen
blanko-check wir erwarten und verlangen
von ihnen dass sie innerhalb der
Koalition eine andere Arbeitsweise sich
aneignen und nicht in letzter Sekunde
uns überrumpeln und beschimpfen weil sie
es nicht hinbekommen haben monatelang
habe die Ampel am Entwurf herum
gebastelt substanziell neues Fehlanzeige
diesen Vorwurf weiß der
Wirtschaftsminister zurück das Gesetz
sei völlig klar heizen in Deutschland
wird jetzt Klima freundlicher der Kern
des Gesetzes
die dekarbonisierung der Dame nicht mehr
immer neue Öl und Gasheizung einbauen
der bleibt erhalten das ganze verzahnt
mit dem Gesetz zu kommunaler Fernwärme
sei der richtige Weg zur wärmewende in
Deutschland von wegen so die CDU den
Menschen im Land sei damit nicht
geheultten
das sieht mehr wert auf dem es
geschrieben ist es ein Gesetz für die
Tonne zwei Stunden Debatte über das
unfertige heizungsgesetz mal wieder ist
Eile geboten wenn es tatsächlich bis zur
Sommerpause in dreieinhalb Wochen
verabschiedet werden soll
die Europäische Zentralbank hat den
Leitzins wenig überraschend ein weiteres
Mal angehoben um einen viertel
Prozentpunkt auf jetzt vier Prozent seit
Juli 2022 ist es die achte Erhöhung
nacheinander
ezb-chefin Lagarde bekräftigte das Ziel
durch die Zinspolitik die Inflation
mittelfristig wieder auf 2% zu drücken
bereits für Juli stellte sie eine
weitere Erhöhung in Aussicht
die letzte Generation löst mit ihrem
Protestaktionen Unmut aus sie blockieren
Straßen kleben sich an Kunstwerke
beschmieren Parteizentralen aber sind
sie deswegen auch extremistisch gar auf
dem Weg zu einer terroristischen
Vereinigung
BKA und Verfassungsschutz sagen dazu
jetzt nein eine Radikalisierung der
Gruppe lassen sich nicht feststellen Jan
Henrich hat mehr
der Streit um die Protestaktionen der
letzten Generation
extremismusvorwürfe gegen die Aktivisten
auf der einen Seite Kritik am harten
Vorgehen der Staatsanwaltschaften bei
Razzien auf der anderen
rollkommandos brechen in Wohnung von
Aktivisten ein das ist natürlich
völlig absurd es ist ja nicht eine
Gründung einer terroristischen
Vereinigung die Diskussion hatte sich in
den vergangenen Wochen und Monaten
hochgeschaukelt Aktivismus oder
Extremismus nicht selten gehen dabei
Begrifflichkeiten Durcheinander von den
Sicherheitsbehörden kommt eine aktuelle
Einordnung es gebe derzeit weder
Erkenntnisse zu möglichen Extremismus
Bezügen noch zu radikalisierungstenzen
insgesamt hat das Bundeskriminalamt seit
Beginn vergangenen Jahres 580 Straftaten
der Gruppe zugeschrieben und ausgewertet
der Großteil davon bei Straßenblockaden
auch das Bundesamt für Verfassungsschutz
bestätigt man sehr aktuell noch keine
Anhaltspunkte für verfassungsfeindliche
Bestrebungen
die zuständige Bundesministerin stellte
heute am Rande der
Innenministerkonferenz ihre Sicht der
Dinge klar
die Grenze ist für mich immer da wo
Straftaten begangen werden das ist nicht
in Ordnung wir gehen da hart als
Rechtsstaat gegenvor über die
Verhältnismäßigkeit von Razzien gegen
klimaaktivisten ist damit allerdings
noch nichts gesagt
auch wenn die letzte Generation bei
ihren Aktionen teilweise Straftaten
begeht ist die Gruppe noch nicht
extremistisch oder ein Fall für den
Verfassungsschutz eine wichtige
Unterscheidung die allerdings auf die
strafrechtlichen Ermittlungen
beispielsweise wegen mutmaßlicher
Bildung einer kriminellen Vereinigung
keinen Einfluss hat und diese
Ermittlungen dauern aktuell noch an
zur flüchtlingskatastrophe in der Ägäis
dort scheinen die schlimmsten
Befürchtungen wahr zu werden nach dem
Untergang eines Schiffes mit hunderten
Menschen an Bord gibt es kaum noch
Hoffnung auf weitere Überlebende
104 Schiffbrüchige konnten gerettet
werden 78 Tote wurden bis gestern
Nachmittag geboren doch an Bord waren
viel mehr Menschen diese Bilder machte
die griechische Küstenwache vor dem
Unglück offenbar befanden sich im
Inneren noch einmal ebenso viele
Menschen wie ein Deck auch viele Kinder
wahrscheinlich sind sie mit dem Boot
untergegangen
an Bord waren auch Flüchtlinge aus
Syrien das Land ist kriegsgebeutelt im
Februar wurde der Norden Syriens auch
noch von einem verheerenden Erdbeben
erschüttet erschüttert dabei starben
tausende Menschen viele weitere wurden
obdachlos bei einer eu-geberkonferenz in
Brüssel haben mehrere Staaten Hilfen von
rund 10 Milliarden Dollar für syrische
Flüchtlinge zugesagt wie ist die
Menschen nach dem Beben in den
betroffenen Gebieten geht zeigt
ihres nah der türkischen Grenze
vier Monate ist das Erdbeben nun her
aber ingenderes in Nordwesten Syriens
wird immer noch der Schutt beiseite
geschafft und ist nichts wieder
aufgebaut oder repariert
statt der Zelte stehen jetzt Container
vor dem einzigen Krankenhaus der Stadt
die Ärzte hatten große Hoffnungen in die
Vereinten Nationen gesetzt deren Helfer
erstmals des syrische oppositionsgebiet
besuchten aber nichts passiert die
medizinische Versorgung ist schlechter
als vor dem Leben
die meiste Hilfe ging damals an die
regimegebiete auf Kosten der am meisten
betroffenen Gebiete hier aber Hilfe und
hilfsverteilung müssen fair sein nicht
politisch
eine
un-untersuchungskommission nannte die
ausbleibenden Hilfen damals schockierend
und machte die syrische Regierung und
die unende für verantwortlich kein
Trinkwasser kein Kühlschrank keine
Waschmaschine
seine Frau im Erdbeben er zieht die
Kinder allein groß im Zelt wenn er
Medizin oder Wasser braucht für sie muss
er etwas aus dem gespendeten Essenspaket
verkaufen er sorgt sich dass sie seit
Monaten keine Schule mehr haben
keine einzige Organisation und half mir
mit irgendetwas in diesem Zelt wird es
sehr heiß es gibt keine Isolation es
gibt keinen Ventilator nichts
der humanitäre Hilfsplan der UN ist seit
Jahren unterfinanziert doch der Bedarf
vor Ort war noch nie so groß
eine schockierte Nachricht kommt von
einem der beliebtesten Reiseziele in
Deutschland Schloss Neuschwanstein nach
einem Angriff in der Nähe der
Sehenswürdigkeit ist eine
US-Amerikanerin gestorben eine andere
schwerer Verletzungen die beiden jungen
Touristinnen wurden offenbar von einem
Landsmann attackiert und in eine
Schlucht gestoßen er wurde wegen
Mordverdacht festgenommen Alexander Pool
berichtet
möglicherweise führt die Polizei hier
den Mann ab der gestern Nachmittag zwei
Frauen bei Schloss Neuschwanstein einen
Abhang hinunter gestoßen haben soll Eric
ob Mary einen Amerikaner hat diese
Bilder gedreht
als der Mann an mir vorbei lief sagte er
kein Wort er hatte viele Kratzer in
seinem Gesicht und am Nacken
bei den mutmaßlichen Täter handelt es
sich laut Polizei um einen
amerikanischen Touristen er soll zwei
junge Amerikanerinnen auf einen
Trampelpfad gelockt haben dort griff er
eine der beiden an als ihre Freundin zu
Hilfe eilt wird sie von dem Mann einen
50 Meter tiefen Abhang hinunter gestoßen
danach versucht er wohl die andere Frau
zu vergewaltigen und stößt sie ebenfalls
in den Abgrund
beide Frauen wurden in ein Krankenhaus
geflogen wo die jüngere im Laufe der
gestrigen Nacht an ihren Verletzungen
starb der mutmaßliche Täter konnte in
der Nähe des Tatorts festgenommen werden
er ist heute dem Ermittlungsrichter am
Amtsgericht in Kempten vorgeführt worden
und sitzt jetzt den Untersuchungshaft
ein Geständnis gibt es bislang nicht das
Tatmotiv unklar
das Bundesumweltministerium ist
alarmiert in Seitenkanälen der oder in
Polen sind tote Fische entdeckt worden
die Sorge vor einer Umwelt-
damals starben hunderttausende Fische
der Grund auf polnischer Seite des
Grenzflusses waren laut Fachleuten große
Mengen Salz ins Wasser geleitet worden
dadurch vermehrte sich eine giftige Alge
die zum Massensterben führte oder selbst
ist derzeit jedoch nicht betroffen Jan
Meyer berichtet
es sind nur wenige tote Fische in einem
Nebenarm der oder die ein polnischer
Nachrichtensender zeigt hier im
gleiwitzer-kanal wurde bei Wasserproben
das Gift der Gold Alge nachgewiesen die
Alge die wir eigentlich erst im Sommer
erwartet hatten zeigt uns gerade sie
kann das auch schon bei 12 Grad
Wassertemperatur ganz prima Fische
umbringen das ist diese Ohnmacht diese
diese Machtlosigkeit die man hat man
sieht dass es dem Fluss schlecht geht
man sieht dass es wieder passieren kann
und man kann nichts dagegen tun mehrere
hundert Tonnen Fische starben im
vergangenen August bei der
Umweltkatastrophe in Deutsch polnischen
Grenzfluss die Schuldigen hat Polen bis
heute nicht benannt Anfang der Woche
räumte Umweltministerin moskverein das
ist auch in diesem Jahr wieder Probleme
gibt natürlich wir haben viele Mittel
für Kläranlagen bereitgestellt so haben
wir die salz-einladungen reduziert aber
an einigen Stellen sind die Einleitungen
für uns immer noch eine Herausforderung
die Meldungen aus Polen sorgen bei ihrer
Amtskollegin in Berlin für Alarmstimmung
es bleibt bestehen dass die Einleitungen
die salz-einleitungen reduziert werden
müssen wenn man die Katastrophe
verhindern will und das passiert im
Moment offensichtlich auf polnischer
Seite nicht das ist ein Problem auch
über 500 Kilometer Fluss abwärts am
unteren oder Tal haben Forscher
goldalgen gefunden das Ökosystem des
Flusses ist aus dem Gleichgewicht
geraten und hat sich noch nicht wieder
erholt die Folgen einer zweiten
Katastrophe wäre nicht abzusehen
und jetzt kommen wir zur
Fußballnationalmannschaft Norbert das
nächste Test morgen Abend in Warschau
gegen Polen ja und da will das Team nach
dem enttäuschenden 3:3 gegen die Ukraine
natürlich ganz anders auftreten
Bundestrainer Flick muss aber auf die
Verletzten Werner und Klostermann
verzichten und der frischgebackene
Champions League Sieger Gündogan der
wird auch noch nicht spielen
der ManCity Kapitän und der
Bundestrainer begrüßen sich beim
Abschlusstraining vor der Abreise nach
Warschau herzlich führen 10 Minuten lang
ein intensives Gespräch Gündogan zur
Zeit den Top Form könnte der DFB elf die
dringend benötigte Kreativität und
Stabilität im Mittelfeld verleihen doch
in Polen muss die Mannschaft von Hansi
Flick ohne ihn auskommen gerade in der
Ende der der Saison in der Liga in der
Premier League aber auch im Pokal weil
da wirklich einer der vorangegangen ist
und äh ja von daher tut es uns gut auch
ihn bei uns zu haben weil wir wollen
jetzt auch gewinnen weil es einfach auch
wichtig ist dass man Spiele gewinnt weil
es einfach mehr Vertrauen gibt auch in
die eigene Qualität das Duell morgen
Abend gegen den Nachbarn mehr als ein
Testspiel eine Niederlage und die Krise
der deutschen Mannschaft würde sich
weiter verschärfen
heute Abend nicht nations liegt das
zweite Halbfinale Spanien gegen Italien
der Gewinner trifft auf Kroatien das
gestern Abend die Niederlande mit vier
zu zwei besiegt hatte
die kroatischen Fans machen die Rechnung
zunächst ohne die Nachspielzeit aus dem
0:1-rückstand hat ihr Team eine 2:1
Führung gemacht doch in der sechsten
Minute der Nachspielzeit gleich Norland
für die Niederlande aus in der
Verlängerung gibt Chancen hier wieder
aber erst Bruno Petkovic gelingt in der
98 minute die Führung für die Gäste
ein Foul Elfmeter von Luca Modric
springt Kroatien den vier zu zwei Sieg
im nations League Finale am Sonntag kann
Kroatien den ersten Titel gewinnen
Jan Lennart Stoff hat beim ATP Turnier
in Stuttgart das Viertelfinale erreicht
mit einem Ass verwandelte er seinen
dritten Matchball gegen den
US-Amerikaner Tommy Paul ein hart
umkämpftes Spiel zwei Sätze zweimal
typic Strumpf trifft morgen auf den
Griechen nicht der verlustsizipas oder
den Franzosen geschah das geht
das war's vom Sport
morgen kommt etwas mehr Bewegung ins
Wetter im Nordosten regnet es auch mal
etwas intensiver einzelheiten dazu
gleich von Katja Hornbach das heute
journal können Sie um 21:45
[Musik]
guten Abend heute brachte das Höhentief
von Polen deutlich mehr Wolken mit und
es gab auch ein kleines bisschen Regen
die Quellwolken breiteten sich weiter in
Richtung Westen aus als noch gestern
heute Nacht gibt es auch einige
Regenschauer in Mecklenburg-Vorpommern
zum Beispiel auch in Niedersachsen und
am Alpenrand im Westen ist es dagegen
klar der winterzug kommt aus West
nordwestlichen Richtungen und die
Temperaturen sinken an der Nordsee und
am Niederrhein bis 14 Grad bis auf 8
Grad geht es in den östlichen
Mittelgebirgen runter und morgen liegen
die Höchsttemperaturen in der Uckermark
und auch in den östlichen Mittelgebirgen
so um 19 Grad deutlich wärmer wird es am
Rhein mit bis zu 28 Grad und morgen gibt
es deutlich mehr Wolken als heute und
das kann auch etwas länger regnen bis zu
5 Liter Regen pro Quadratmeter sind
möglichen Mecklenburg-Vorpommern
nördlichen Brandenburg und auch in
Niedersachsen am Nachmittag entwickeln
sich dann vor allen Dingen über den
östlichen Mittelgebirgen Regenschauer
und Gewitter im
Westen das dagegen trocken bei
nordwestend Regenschauer und Gewitter
werden sich am Wochenende auf den
Nordosten und Osten beschränken sonst
gibt's viel Sonnenschein und am Montag
dreht die Wetterlage auf Südwest es wird
schwül warm und gewittrig ich wünsche
Ihnen einen schönen Abend